politics it's in our corporations it's
in our religious institutions and of
course what's it in well it's in all of
our movies and our television and the
rest of the stuff that we show once
again our kids uh this is really wild
you guys know that in a couple weeks if
you haven't seen it it's all over online
everywhere the Barbie movie is coming
out uh Mary Margaret olahan uh tweeted
this out uh Barbie release on July 21st
there's a ton of hype around this movie
what you may have missed it includes a
biologically male actor who identifies
as a woman playing a female doctor and
there's the biological male
who plays a female in the movie who not
plays a female who is a female is quote
unquote is a female in the movie
um the point of all of this guys it I
don't have a problem with the Trans
person being an actor or anything else
as you know or not even a trans person
you want to dress up like a chick and go
get a gig like you want to be a plumber
that would be funny like you you you
know you got like a you got a clogged
toilet you call the plumber and then
like you know like a dude in a dress
shows up like I'll fix her toilet
um
I don't have a problem with any of that
but the point is Barbie is made for
children now I get it everyone's stuck
in like some weird adolescent thing so
it'll be mostly 35 year olds going to
see this thing but they are
intentionally trying there's a gajillion
girls out there who would love to be in
the Barbie movie as a girl so why do
they go out of their way to have a
biological boy play a girl who's
supposed to be completely a girl in the
Barbie movie unless they're trying to
confuse kids unless they want some kid
to realize something's a little weird
about that some eight-year-old kid is
going to watch the Barbie movie be like
something's a little odd there and then
bring that up with their parents and
then their parents have to explain that
to them when all they wanted to do was
get two hours of Peace on a Saturday
afternoon by taking them to our movies
[Music]
thank you